um
no but it's crazy because you guys went
through all these errors of music
some of it was microwavable but like and
then the hs87 wave hit
hit boy becomes the biggest producer in
the world yeah
uh that was what [ __ ] 2011 is when watch
the throne came out
yeah so that's like 2012 and then 2012
is when
he got the deal by that time you would
already um
soon move on from the production deal
originally yeah but like so
around like just to give like a quick
little boom like after we like
let's say like 2010 you know what i'm
saying we were
[ __ ] two three songs into the deal
[ __ ] wasn't really trying to give us
no money
i had real relationships chris brown
invited us on like this huge ass
tour at this restaurant out here in
hollywood he looked me and my face was
like man y'all come on the tour man
y'all good
all y'all gotta do is get a tour bus and
y'all good for every day and they have
bread for us we just had to get a bus
and we didn't know the game interscope
wouldn't even pay for the bus it was 60
racks
it was stupid little petty [ __ ] like
that that like we didn't know no better
saying that to say um we but i knew
enough to be like yo this [ __ ] is whack
you feel me and then uh me and octane
like they start kind of like
turning us against each other they start
getting weird early but this is my
brother
so if we were never able to do nothing
it was always like get in the room and
chop it up like [ __ ] what's good
right this [ __ ] is out you feel me so
that's what we did
i let [ __ ] know like yo i'm up out of
here like i ain't [ __ ] with this
production that [ __ ] none of this [ __ ]
no more
um we had the option at the time of
interscope everybody had left you know
that signed us all this [ __ ] so we had
the option to stare go
we left moved back to the hood with the
little bit of bread i had i moved back
literally to the hood too like i was
around the corner from the block like
and um i had a little bread so like
in the hood we were stars everywhere we
go eat the [ __ ] so let's pop in
make a long story shirt we made i'll
start producing it and we did a song
called throw it back in the song called
crap it up
that both did a million views and [ __ ]
on youtube and [ __ ] remember
you feel me as kids so this is no hit
boy no no
interest coming or nothing [ __ ] in
rialto me producing
it my [ __ ] doing our thing and that
started like making even just like the
hit boy just [ __ ] like our
brothers and [ __ ] even respecting things
like [ __ ]
we was doing a lot more even so i
started getting around here boy more
outside of this [ __ ] before he
was doing his deal we been knowing him
right right
so when he first got his deal you know
he called me like on me when jimmy ivey
wanted to
when he offered him the deal he called
me i remember i was in the bay
he called me and he was like yo i'm
about to do this [ __ ]
come move it in the guy when he moved
with him you know and uh where he had a
little apartment like north hollywood
when i tell you this thinking hitboy
didn't smack the baddest [ __ ] in the
game i'm not even
here just know this man didn't crack
the goats at these like all the so he
[ __ ] rihanna
i don't know about that
but that nigga's the god i'm just saying
i said cause i remember being in his
little apartment when we had our mansion
she was different but
when i was in his apartment like i lived
in this i was sleeping on his couch so
i'm watching
i'm waking up to the girls walking out
like oh [ __ ]
like damn that's that's
so it was a while a little time but um
that's my brother that's why i could
talk that [ __ ]
shout out to hip hop no he didn't he was
for sure yeah he would go to
so many levels but hey well we're gonna
get to i want to get to the house a hit
too
but um all right so he hit y'all
hs 87 to me was something that was dope
it was like y'all can't money i forget
the girl's name
beat mac the queen shot yeah mac the
queen beat care g
right [ __ ] uh hey banger
um what the [ __ ] is this kate roosevelt
okay roosevelt
yeah come on man okay roosevelt's still
going crazy yeah he's fine
um but now but like what do you think
what do you think went wrong with hs87
or why do you think it didn't work out
like
i thought it was going to obviously i
thought it was gonna be crazy man listen
hsa7
was like the biggest [ __ ] ever which we
didn't even realize until after
when people be telling us how we were
when we walked in rooms and like the
perception between you know
you know what i mean but the real reason
that
i personally think it didn't work out
other than just divine timing
um was just hit boy was the biggest
producer in the world
as well as hitboy can actually rap and
make dope music you know what i'm saying
he was really
inspired to make you know um his own
music
you know do a solo thing and i think it
was a lot of
people in the his corner and
in his ear no i don't think i know it
was a lot of people in this corner in
his ear and the wrong people in his
corner in his ear that just was just
giving him wrong advice
in game you know as simple as that that
like
um on what he should have been doing
with the budget and then we from
ie we kids like that don't know [ __ ]
[ __ ] just get broke like i remember
like hit boy being at my cribs spending
the night before i remember hit boy
being at our producer's crib
snugging like him ain't always been up
and rich either you know so
when that [ __ ] start getting that crazy
bread like he trusting these people
you know so when they not telling that
[ __ ] to put
200 000 at radio behind k roosevelt
as he should have that do me now record
was out of here that you know or
when they're not telling this [ __ ] to
put you know 200 000
to whatever [ __ ] anything whatever
behind shine or whatever
because he's not knowing to and
obviously he's not finished
so i think it was [ __ ] like i think it's
i told hit this i told him that i think
he's improved so much as an emcee
and i feel like he's he's taken huge
strides in that direction
yeah i feel like initially he
[Music]
he had you can't money
i feel like he could have eased into the
rapping [ __ ] a little bit
slower you know what i'm saying that
makes sense yeah 100
i mean because hit boy is rapping
better than everyone now no no he could
rap his like i just like
initially i feel like he he came into
the game like it went from him being the
biggest producer in the game
to him it almost felt like solely
focusing on rapping
yeah and and he was and it was like all
right well which it wasn't a bad idea
because he had good
no he had a great record bro then the
[ __ ] dropped jay-z interview like what
we got
the interview was crazy and that [ __ ]
went so crazy
that you would be foolish to not
like go full speed ahead you know what i
mean but
i think like me and my cousin was just
banging a [ __ ] hip boy versus going
crazy this nigga's a nut right like his
right hand he's killing it now that's
right
this whole project he dropped he threw
out two projects this year the [ __ ] with
dom and his solo [ __ ]
but the reason why i feel like he's
going so crazy now is because
he's the where he's at in the production
i feel like low-key
when you get to the point where you're
like
as big as he was and then
it almost feels like
he had he he's got a chip on his
shoulder again because
i feel like people stop mentioning him
in those conversations that he should
always be mentioned in
yeah and i think it was because he was
so focused on hs87
right and and and and that whole era of
his career that it took away from hit
boy the producer so now i feel like he's
just
and he's been on his [ __ ] for like dude
and i'm gonna tell you bro
really really not just this year by the
way no no no no every year hey boy got
at least ten places
but the thing is too like at that time
specifically we were really on some [ __ ]
too where we was like yo we finna
challenge the game
the beat sounded wild like granted now
[ __ ] beats and [ __ ] sound like what we
was doing bro i remember i was at i was
at y'all's crib
in uh encino or where was it at tarzan
tarzana i was over there bro and you
guys played me grinding my whole life
yeah and i was blown away
it was like the hardest [ __ ] i ever
heard yeah i was like
this is the craze this is the chris
since i grinded from the clips this [ __ ]
is so hard like
literally some of the beasts i mean the
beast was so nutty that like people
didn't get them
you didn't get it and so like a person
that just raps too crazy and so it's
just going over your head
like [ __ ] daylight you know what i'm
saying like
that was how the beats were you know
even though we left the beats were crazy
listen real music [ __ ] loved
them everyone loved them but
the people the people who aren't music
like
kids that are in their [ __ ] car going
to school that one mcdonald's on the way
don't understand the beast didn't
understand what he was doing that's why
everything that man is touching now is
translating he gets it he got the rules
he cracked the code yeah you guys you
think later on like looking back people
have
kind of caught on to it you know like a
movie will come out and then like later
on it's like a cult classic
yeah but it didn't do nothing but make
the people who did catch it like only go
in
like embrace hey boy more or embrace us
more that really did [ __ ] with us
right embrace like the people who are
catching it late they just coming to
[ __ ] with us now
and the